the fact that they picked the Wayne is
ridiculous over 10 Kevin Harts have you
ever seen a pack of hyenas those other
animals don't stand a chance cuz they
lure him into a trap 10 Kevin hars we'll
the Wayne up give me 10 Kevin hars we'll
whoop his ass he don't stand a chance
hey what's going on my name is Kevin har
right now we're going to find out what
the lad Bible audience thought about me
okay here we
go what percentage of people asked said
that they were taller than Kevin Hart oh
um all right what of people I'm going to
go with 77% said they were taller than
me yeah I'm going to go d uh 76 to 100%
of people thought that they were taller
than me let's see here D all right 82%
by the way you guys are all [__] but
you don't know you don't know how tall I
am and I'm like 5'4 and A2 and today I
got on the boot so I'm probably like 5'5
and A2 so just let you know I'm not like
I'm not like weird small I'm very like
proportion from my side so it's not like
a freakishly small thing when you see me
oh he's he's small but he's not like
small small I'm not a double small
that's a good way to explain it what
character does Kevin Hart most resemble
okay here we go baby
Yoda
Pikachu
Stitch Wall-E who's who's WALL-E WALL-E
who's that you know the little robot in
the Pixar film I think I'm a robot what
is that um I'm wise I'm a small wise man
I'm going to go baby Yoda baby
Yoda
Stitch [__] baby Yoda man I mean Stitch
isn't bad but I would said baby Yoda
baby Yoda was second though so that was
close what does Kevin Hart want for his
birthday okay this is should be good
let's see here links Africa deodorant
people saying a stink what is it a hug
stilts all right no I don't want no damn
stilts if anything a hug hugs are always
nice hug is a gift that just keeps on on
giv so I would have said a hug stilton's
very cruel here we go back to the height
I'm not that small I can't wait for a
lot of these people to see me in person
so they can be in awe how also do have a
little present for you here we do have
some links Africa if you want oh wow uh
wh why did you guys go to Africa to get
like what's going on where do they sell
this this is like a staple Christmas
present I don't think a Christmas has
gone by when my dad has not given me one
of them links okay so this is probably
like our X I guess yeah yeah see that
see how I just did that right there see
I just combined that that's that's what
I do that's the genius of me that's the
baby odor in okay now what I want you to
do is hold this for me and I want you to
rewrap it and give it back to your dad
okay all right all right let's see here
what team is Kevin har on Team Edward
Team Jacob what is this have you ever
seen Twilight oh my God all the time
um uh uh I'm Team Jacob
oh my God I was yeah they're right they
know me and what is it that you love
about Jacob so much Jacob what do I love
about Jacob that's a stupid question
what don't you love about Jacob you got
to love everything about Jacob come on
man like the way he talks and the way
the way he does cool stuff right like I
think we do a lot of a lot of the stuff
the same so that's why I love him
everybody knows that me and Jacob do
some cool stuff so there it is that's
why which Kevin has a superior meme a
Kevin Hart or B Kevin James I don't know
they went on a meme frenzy with me uh
last year so I'm going to go me I'm GNA
say
me wow really Kevin James Kevin are
funny though the the whole show cuz
they're very sitcom me all of Kevin
James memes were like very sitcom in the
show or face that you can attach but I
had a lot of stupid ones too I love that
it was close what's the best meme you've
seen of yourself there's one there's one
that they have with my hands where I'm
like I'm like this and they attach that
to a lot of stuff
like like when you when you don't have
enough money for the bill or when you're
out of excuses but your partner still
wants to argue like it's a lot I've seen
a lot of funny ones there all right who
would kevar call to help him bury a body
oh this guy good Jack Black Snoop Dog
Snoop will phoh Chris Rock oh Mark
Walberg Chris a snitch
I'm not calling Chris will a panic and
like he'll tell me he's going to help me
but he'll stand me up he's not coming
Jack will call the cops before we even
like get into it he like what you're
doing isn't right it's between Snoop and
Mark I want to say Snoop but then I'm
like Snoop might be too high to focus
and he might up the mission so I'm going
to go Mark Mark Wahlberg for sure and I
feel like Mark could have possibly
buried a bite before
Snoop okay Snoop but Mark was second my
two choices were accurate all right uh
would you trust Kevin Hart with the
secret obviously yes yes the answer is
yes no for what what y'all see me blab
about I don't talk about nothing I ain't
never said nothing to nobody about
nothing you just told us Mark walberg's
probably buried a
body I did say that didn't he did just
say that that's a good point it's a good
point which style should Kevin har Go
For A B C or D well A and D are very
close in proximity um I'm going to say a
like just because that's something that
I I've been close
to B what where do you think I'm getting
this here from what do you think I'm
getting here that can lay across my
forehead from who do you think my dad is
Ricky Martin like what what just
happened
now no shot I can get that clearly the
audience want to see it so yeah we have
here a wig for me to do that do you want
to give it a guy let me let me see the
wig no this screams Donald Trump no no
no uh let's go to the next one all right
who would win in a fight one Dwayne
Johnson 10 Kevin hars 10 Kevin hars
we'll the Wayne up give me 10 Kevin hars
we'll whoop his ass he'll stand a chance
I can fight I'm very good with my hands
you better go Google Kevin Harden's
boxing videos I've been fighting for
quite some time the fact that they
picked D Wayne is ridiculous over 10
Kevin Harts have you ever seen a pack of
hyenas like like fight another animal
those other animals don't stand a chance
cuz they lure him into a trap 10 Kevin
Harts will lure him into a trap make him
run what are you going to lure him in
with well it depends uh baby oil Dwayne
he's addicted to baby oil he always
wants to put oil and on his arms like yo
they got to sell on baby oil right here
go in this store and then he goes in
there we him
up what animal does Kevin Hart remind
you of top three answers okay let's see
here a hyena by the way yeah you know I
told you guys 10 Kevin Harts very
similar to a pack of hyenas A Mir cat
what they're like long aren't they I'm
not long a CH waah
Chihuahua small lot of bark and right
Chihuahua will bite your ass so don't
think that chihuahuas are all bark no
bite I've seen Chihuahuas get a hold of
some bigger dogs in my time I love that
people thought I was a Chihuahua that's
very very specific although I do got
some hyena in me okay I laugh and and
kick your ass at the same
time Bam Bam Bam that's what they do how
long will Kevin har surv five in the
zombie apocalypse all right this is good
let's see here what do they say one day
no I'm I'm going to I'm going to last
one week no one month one year no
forever I'm going one
day I'm prepared for the Zombie
Apocalypse Now I'm stocked up on stuff
just in case it ever happens I got to
honestly I think I can go a year I think
I can go a year with the zombie
apocalypse cuz all you got to do is know
how to take down zombies head shot all
day head shot and by the way I'm a great
shot uh I would have tons of weapons
lots of ammunition um I would build a
fort that nobody else can get in except
me I would survive off of like canned
goods that I got in preparation for the
zombie apocalypse I would have one of
those G wagons that I make a tank and I
I cover all the glass with like wood and
stuff and and I got a flamethrower that
I would put on the front of it so
zombies ever got close I set them
[__] on on fire you see what I'm
saying like you don't know how to
survive in a zombie apocalypse I do I
will be a year year for sure the only
reason why I say not forever because if
it goes past year I just want to die
anyway would you do it with anyone else
would you go through the apocalypse with
mates no all my friends are [__] all
right what job would Kevin Har have if
he wasn't a comedian basketball player
probably flight attendant no personal
trainer could be vice
president bluee keeper wow uh I'll be a
basketball player for sure comedy chose
me I chose basketball a four-time MVP
the world knows that the celebrity game
is no longer the same because I remov
myself I'm a Hall of Fame basketball
celebrity game player so the answer
should be basketball God damn it
zookeeper zookeeper I would never be a
zookeeper I'm afraid of animals so those
animals would die under my watch I'm not
feeding them animals no shot K did you
feed the did you feed the ls yeah
yeah they dead they don't stand a chance
oh my God this is great well I got to
see what people say about it more
importantly you got to see what my
responses were to them I think the one
thing we got to fix here is this
assumption that I'm a small guy I'm not
a small guy okay that should be
something within itself but it's
understanding like in my past life I was
a thug y'all don't even know the stuff
that I used to do I used to do a lot of
crazy things with these
hands nobody believes
me this is good
was great thank you so much so funny you
guys always have great stuff my best
feature is where I get in
trouble I know it's like don't don't
please don't don't get canceled um